Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie
Ecoutez aujourd'hui j'suis super content
Parce que la vidéo d'hier soir a plus de 21000 commentaires
C'est l'une des vidéos les plus commentée de ces 6 dernier mois
Donc
Je suppose que vous l'avez grandement appréciée que vous avez voulu me le dire dans les commentaires
Ooooooooh la belle barbe !!
Putain la barbe de ouf Squeezie viril les gars Squeezie viril
La VIRILITÉ
Squeezie de la barbe ... suspect
OH MON DIEU LA BARBE T'AS CHANGÉ SQUEEZIE
*MUSIQUE*
OK OK OK
Il est vrai la barbe a poussé pendant ces 2 semaines aux Etats-Unis
Et je pensais pas que ça vous marquerait autant mais apparement ... ça vous marque
Allez ouvrez vos livres page 47 et lisons tout ça
Avec la barbe je lui donne 30 ans
Je sais ouais je suis viril
Dommage la voix je lui donne 15 ans
Ta barbe fait viril
Arrêtez arrêtez
Ouais sa barbe a poussé mais il a toujours son corps de lâche
ALORS ÇA ALORS ÇA
ça c'est vrai...
Je suis le seul qui a remarqué qu'il y a un prof en jaune en jouet derrière Squeezie
Oh putain enfin quelqu'un qui parle pas de ma barbe mais qui parle de Koro-Sensei
C'est le personnage d'un manga qui s'appelle Assasination Classroom
Voila
Putain rase-toi mec
Eh Bruno Bruno retourne faire le show mon garçon
*sourire*
Ta barbe te donne ce petit côté kawaï
Beaucoup de gens disent que j'ai changé et c'est vrai
Parfois plus mature parfois pas du tout
Voila je vous la mets en tête c'est gratuit
*rire*
Il veut ressembler à Cyprien à se laisser pousser la barbe ?
Pour avoir la barbe de Cyprien déjà il faut avoir 26 ans
Et ensuite il faut la laisser pousser pedant 1 ans sans la toucher !
Rase la barbe t'es mieux sans serieux likez si vous êtes d'accord
Ecoute Naufal Ghifari tu as 1 like
Voila j'en conclus qu'je ne dois pas la raser
J'adore il fait que de se carresser la barbe
Je t'avoue Blooms Mallow que j'ai vu pendant des années dans les films des mecs quand ils réfléchissent qui se grattent la barbe comme ça
Du coup j'en profite et je le fais aussi
Et c'est instinctif c'est même pas voulu
*refléchit* Qu'est ce que je peux dire ensuite comme..?
Ohh pardon j'ai pas fait exprès.
Like si tu trouves que la barbe ça lui va bien je trouve qu'il ressemble plus a un mec xD la virilité ma gueule mdr.
Je sais pas trop comment prendre ce commentaire.
Est-ce que avant je ressemblais du coup a une sorte de femme?
317 likes PUTAAIN GROS BUZZ
Tu sais quoi ?
Hop là ! Allez fait une vidéo toute seule.
Yo tout le monde c'est la barbe de Squeezie aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une nouvelle vidéo
Elle s'est enflamée
Je suis sûr que la prochaine vidéo parlera de sa barbe. 70% des commentaires sont à propos de la barbe à "Squezzir".
Non, je suis original comme youtubeur,
je ferais jamais ça.
Pourquoi "Squezzir" ?
Parce que ça fait zizir. Je mérite combien d'années de prison monsieur le juge ?
30 ans *rire*
OMG cette barbe est magnifique je suis ému !
Merci Mr Newik
Moi aussi je suis ému tous les matins.
Je me dis p***** ça fait 6 ans on attend ça,
ça fait 6 ans on a un corps de lâche et pas de virilité, et là on est au moins
l'un des deux. Ça fait plaisir.
T'as trop de barbe, j'aime pas, moins un abo.
Ah d'accord, on part carrément sur *rire* un désabonnement,
pour des questions esthétiques !
Je te pensais pas comme ça Tom...
Ah pardon j'ai pas fait exprès
Le grand et magnifique Squeezie a arrêté de faire de vraies vidéos
maintenant je pense me désabonner.
Josue Jabol j'ai une question à te poser, quelle vidéo pour toi est une vraie vidéo ?
Je mérite deux gifles pour avoir fait les guillemets avec les mains.
Une vidéo dans laquelle le créa... pfff
T'es pas drôle Squeezie.
J'ai même pas suivi la vidéo tellement sa barbe est si belle.
Black Hole tu veux pécho t'as kiffé la barbe tu veux hé ho !
Tu veux pécho en plus tu t'appelles "trou noir" Black Hole
Ça m'excite un peu tout ça !
Commentaire suivant !
OMG notre petit Squeezie est viril,
notre enfant est devenu un vrai homme ! *rire*
J'adore ces commentaires !
Petit enfant est devenu grand.
C'est super glauque arrêtez p*****.
Les gens qui disent "oh Squeezie a une barbe incroyable", c'est quoi votre problème vous avez jamais vu une barbe ou ?
Eh hop-op-op-op *sifflement*
Tu redescends. Ou c'est sûrement le fait que vous en avez pas encore car vous n'avez que 13 ans et que vous jouez à Minecraft. Ho là ho !
*sifflements*
Je trouve que cette barbe de quelques jours lui va très bien, mdr.
Lol.
Squeezie pourquoi tu mets un casque alors qu'il n'y a pas de son ?
Ecoute je l'ai laissée pousser pendant 3 se...
C'est vrai.
Mais non mais [sérieux] il est obligé de le mettre dans toutes les vidéos ?!
Ouais ouais ouais c'est vrai ouais.
Pas du tout c'est juste un réflexe en faite.
Ouais ouais mytho placement
de produit, placement de produit !
Vos gueules p***** !
La barbe de ouf de Squeezie likez si vous aussi vous trouvez qu'il a une superbe barbe.
*Clic* Y a aucun narcissisme dans ce que je viens de faire.
Oh p*****, ça j'adore !
Je suis une grande fan de Squeezie, ou du moins je l'étais,
je trouve que ces vidéos sont beaucoup moins intéressantes,
je trouve, personnellement, que les vidéos sont devenues commerciales.
Tu sais ce qui est beau dans cette histoire Anaïs,
c'est que t'as le même nom de famille que moi.
Voila. Le reste c'est pas beau. *rire*
La maturité du jeu précédent à fait comprendre à ta barbe qu'il était temps
de pousser ou elle a pris une substance quelconque ? Je fais appel à l'inspecteur Squeezie !
Non Jadhélie fais pas ça non Jadhé...
Wo-po-po-po c'est quoi cette petite be-bar là ?
En fait je suis parti aux US pendant deux semaines et je me suis jamais rasé donc...
Chhuuuut... T-t-t-t-t...
[Elle a] Pas mal poussée du coup ouais ça me fait une grosse...
T-t-t-t-t...
barbe.
T-t-t-t-t-t-t...
Be-bar.
B***.
*Tir* Oh perdu !
Mes amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo.
Mais jusqu'où donc poussera cette be-bar ?
Rejoindrons-nous les plus grands ?
Ou les plus petits ?
Nous ne pouvons pas savoir mais je suis fier de vous annoncer qu'après 5 ans d'attente
un début de virilité est enfin apparu.
Encore une fois merci à tous d'avoir...
cru en ma virilité depuis...
Ah d'accord le générique il veut carrément pas que je vous remercie.
Sinon vu que c'est ma vidéo je peux peut-être...
Eh oh tu vas te détendre générique de m... !
Abonnez-vous.